and we begin with this breaking news out
of Northeastern Egypt a huge fire has
engulfed the security directorate
building in the city of iselia the area
is on the West Bank of the Su Canal
officials say the fire has been
contained but the cause not yet known
the health Ministry is reporting at
least 38 people have been injured there
are local media reports that nearby
hospitals have been put on alert iselia
is one of the cities that overlooks
Egypt's Su Canal a vital Waterway
between Asia and Europe that sees about
10% of the world's Maritime trade sarak
Kira is the founder and director of
European North African Center for
research you're joining us from K from
uh Cairo today look accidental fires
absolutely do happen Sara but in this
case given the nature of the building
the security directorate we have to ask
whether there might be something more to
this your first thoughts when you saw
the security directorate was on fire
well thank you for having me first
thoughts on the fire that it wasn't uh
merely an accident especially that Egypt
is witnessing um presidential elections
and a couple of months from now and the
police department has been always a
target for some Terror attacks so uh
Egyptians woke up to this news today and
uh thanks God there are no uh um death
casualties in that uh incident but uh
official
statements hasn't mentioned anything
more then it's just an accident now but
the timing and the place and the fact
that it's again another Police
Department uh it might be the start of
some something before the elections and
it might be just one another a accident
sure you say the timing and the place
are notable talk to us about
that well the time com that the
campaigning has been started and uh
campaigning for the presidential
elections uh uh um a lot of uh uh
speculations about that Cairo and a lot
of fear among uh uh Egyptians that we
might face another bombings or other
Terror attacks you know that Cairo has
faced that before and uh we don't want
any turbulence before the election so um
hopefully it's not the start of
something ugly before the
elections um especially that again
another Police Department another
coastal city that has
importance uh so hopefully it's not the
start of something ugly and it might be
just another accident as as it's been
stated you say police is often attacked
by
whom well uh you know the the the the
Egypt's war on terror locally and
especially in Sinai has taken a lot of
the Egyptian resources and a lot of the
Egyptian uh thoughts and um we have
spent a lot on securing especially Cairo
because it's been all over the news that
everywhere has been bombarded after the
the the outset of out of uh uh Muslim
brotherhoods uh well we cannot say any
speculations now on uh it might be a
terror attack or not but you know we
have been uh we had Isis and Sinai there
might be another elements still hiding
in in a city like
isia uh so
um it might be another um we we have
fear of Terror attacks and we have
witnessed that uh ever since the uh 20
2011 Revolution and then the 2013
Revolution uh we have had elements that
didn't respect the desire of the
Egyptian people and hopefully we uh we
we we don't experience that again look
we fully appreciate that you're trying
to you know not go beyond what we know
and we know very little at this point
while also bringing us insights and
Analysis and that's exactly why we
wanted to talk to you can you talk to us
about the challenge that something like
this could represent to Egyptian
authorities because this is one Link in
the entire security apparatus that's
been attacked and it it's been I beg
your pardon let me correct that language
we don't know that it has been attacked
there was a fire let me correct that
language but it has been weakened in a
very visible
way yes well the fact that it it's fire
not a bomb or something bombarded or a
car or like we used to to have inside
the streets of Cairo before like the
many instance so the fact that it's fire
and
not bombing car or anything uh this
gives it like 60% it might be an
accident but uh again again the fact
that this place
precisely is on Fire H especially that
this kind of places have huge security
have uh uh um specialized ambulance cars
always uh uh nearby uh it's a very
important place so to be set on fire in
that timing of the day and in that place
especially uh we have to wait for the
laboratory the criminal laboratory of
course there will be statements if it's
if it's an incident if it's a just an
accident
we would say thank God if it's not then
I think there will be um a lot of
statements about it and and and details
on how it happened but thanks God it's
not a bomb or anything yeah so it might
still be an accident because it's just
the fire and everything it might be a a
cureless some cess Behavior we hope we
hope some cess Behavior but the timing
and the city and the building itself
gives us an Insight or maybe a little
bit of analysis that it might be uh set
up yeah you've definitely put that on
our radar Sara Kira founder and director
of the European North African Center for
research thank you for joining us this
hour